si on considère parce qu'il y a deux
façons de d'exercer le pouvoir soit
aimer le pouvoir pour le pouvoir soit
aimer les gens qui vous ont donné le
pouvoir avec la préoccupation permanente
de leur faire du bien et pas de rester à
arc-boutés sur des décisions parce qu'on
les a annoncé parce qu'on les a prises
politique il peut dire je me suis trompé
je vais revenir en arrière ce que vous
l'auriez fait vous si vous aviez été
bien sûr j'ai fait pour les lèvres
exactement
si vous vous souvenez quand on avait le
nombre des morts
je me suis commencé til qui est pas dans
l'appareil d'État quelqu'un qui dise
mais arrêtez avec cette comptabilité
ayez au moins un monde de condoléances
parce que derrière les chiffres c'est
quand même des gens qui permettent un
être cher il y avait pas un mot de
condoléances c'était ce que j'appelle ce
que je décortique et j'explique c'est la
politique par la peur on fait peur aux
gens pour qu'ils obéissent